results are in Iraq's provincial
election marks a major victory for the
coordination framework an umbrella block
of Iraqi Shiite parties aligned with
Iran candidates stay back have dominated
in at least eight provinces another
major winner is oured Speaker Muhammad
Hali whose block tum or Advance took the
most votes in the capital Bagdad and Al
lar
Province the coordination framework is
one despite the boycott but those who
boycotted also won because they proved
their point and strength this divide
could help end the Monopoly of the power
of the ruling Coalition the Electoral
commission announced the results the day
after the ballot it says voter turnout
was at 41% despite a call by the main
opposition the sist movement led by Shia
leader M to boycott the
election they changed the number of
Voters and slashed around 8 million from
the list the real percentage is below 30
% the discussion about the turnout and
the legitimacy of the vote isn't
expected to end at any time soon now
aside from the debate about the
politically motivated boycots this is
the second consecutive election that
more than half the Iraqi population has
chosen not to vote prompting questions
about the Public's confidence in the
entire political system Ali Hashim Al
jaaz
Bagdad make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz